les escrocs peuvent se faire passer pour
quelqu'un en qui vous avez confiance
comme une banque un ami ou un service en
ligne veuillez rentrer vos données
personnelles tenez voici toutes mes
coordonnées privées
et puis bon je t'ai bien oui tout est
donné sans moi
oh non c'est l'ordi menteur le célèbre
voleur de données
mais qui êtes-vous ah je suis Captain
Nord VPN et tu ne voleras pas ces
données vivement l'embrun car grâce à la
protection anti-monaces non VPN peut
reconnaître de nombreux liens
malveillants et vous avertir des sites
web dangereux pour vous empêcher de
cliquer sur un lien suspect et d'être
victime d'une attaque par fishing oh non
regardez Captain c'est dark web
je vais vous tisser dessus
oh mon dieu il a volé nos données il va
les mettre sur le Dark web
je peux recevoir des alertes sur mes
informations d'identification qui
apparaissent sur des sites web
clandestins et en le couplant avec
Nord-Pas je peux générer et remplir
automatiquement des mots de passe fort
allez
[Musique]
merci Captain Nord VPN vous avez
vraiment une solution à tout
moment
et en ce moment profitez d'une réduction
exclusive en passant par le lien en
description vous avez 30 jours satisfait
ou remboursé
[Musique]
tu veux un fortune cookie ah ouais
merci alors qu'est-ce que j'ai
vous allez mourir aujourd'hui
[Musique]
super sympa tu sais très bien que c'est
des conneries qui mettent dedans
[Musique]
le mec à votre droite va mourir
aujourd'hui
tout le monde sait que le destin ça
existe pas
[Musique]
sinon docteur House c'est pas Mickey
Mouse
pourquoi on avait installé ça déjà
[Musique]
oh j'ai une crampe oh
ce que je suis
oh mon dieu je suis mort et je suis un
enfer
[Musique]
suivant monsieur
grenier oui oui
monsieur Lopez mon boulanger pourquoi
vous êtes ici vous vous souvenez de mes
meringues oui elles étaient délicieuses
n'est-ce pas oui d'habitude on met des
blancs d’œufs dedans oui et ben moi
c'était du foot oui non on se dépêche là
on a pas toutes les ternité
enfin si
allez on reprend moi cette discussion
plus tard
excusez-moi vous avez les droits pour la
musique
[Musique]
alors là Monsieur grenier ça fait super
plaisir de vous voir je tiens à vous
dire qu'ici en enfer on est super fan
c'est moi qui vais m'occuper de vérifier
votre dossier pour l'admission
d'être là écoutez je veux juste regarder
votre dossier effectivement il y a pas
grand chose
peut-être une heure vous savez quoi j'ai
juste à vérifier votre compte Twitter
pour être sûr avant de vous renvoyer au
paradis et où là ça va c'était une
blague
c'était une autre époque c'était marrant
et puis il y avait un contexte aussi
justement parlons de contexte
il y a pas moyen peut-être de ça ranger
de régler ça entre nous peut-être
moi je vous aime bien on peut peut-être
trouver un moyen de s'arranger vous
connaissez la Bible vous l'avez lu non
j'ai eu la flamme
voilà quelque chose qu'on donne pour
aider les enfants qui vont en enfer vous
aimez je pourrais n'est-ce pas non je
sais vous savez quoi si vous voulez au
paradis à une seule solution je vais
vous renvoyer sur terre vous allez jouer
à des jeux sur la Bible et ensuite vous
revenez et on va voir si on peut
s'arranger avec
Dieu non le responsable administratif au
premier étage qui est Dieu effectivement
allez attends
sur Terre vous êtes prêts
allez c'est parti bon voyage
[Musique]
monsieur veuillez me suivre vers la
sortie
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien je suis pas en train de t'arracher
tes dents en or je vais dormir moi non
plus
[Musique]
parallèlement à Mario Sonic tous ces
trucs il existe une catégorie de jeux
dont on n'a pas du tout parlé c'est les
jeux éducatifs et vous en connaissez
forcément quelques-uns Adibou par
exemple très certainement le plus connu
de son genre mais c'est un peu trop
récent pour moi j'étais déjà grand quand
c'est sorti alors que pourtant les jeux
éducatifs ça existait déjà quand j'étais
gosse il y a eu pas mal de jeux
éducatifs par exemple avec Mario ou
Carmen San Diego il y avait aussi des
jeux éducatifs sur les maladies Captain
nevelin Rex Ronan Brachy the
Brachiosaurus il y avait même des
consoles éducatives comme la segapico
mais il existe une sous-catégorie de ces
jeux là c'est les jeux sur la religion
et plus particulièrement les jeux sur la
Bible et avant que certains demandent on
a regardé pour l'Islam et le judaïsme
mais effectivement il existe quelques
jeux dessus comme par exemple le slim 3D
un jeu éducatif sur l'islam plutôt
récent qui vous fait voyager jusqu'à La
Mecque ou Mendels Quest un genre de
Runner autour du judaïsme sur Android
mais tout ça ce sont des jeux très
récents et en vrai la majorité des jeux
sur la religion qu'on trouve sont
surtout des jeux basés sur le
catholicisme et on va commencer par un
des plus anciens Bible adventures et oui
vous avez remarqué cette couleur de
grenouille et des naze bien loin du gris
tern habituel des jeunesses et bien ça
c'est parce que c'est un jeu non
approuvé par Nintendo c'est à ça que
c'est à cette fameuse petite marque sur
les jeux Nintendo le fameux Nintendo
seal of quality qui est censé montrer
que le jeu est digne de sortir sur la
console voilà ça c'est à la version
officielle parce que officiellement
c'était plus une histoire de business
allez donc on va commencer par bébé
Moïse le jeu est donc un jeu d'escorte
où vous devez ramasser bébé Moïse et la
compagnie à travers les niveaux en
prenant garde aux araignées et aux
soldats du pharaon oui alors très
important on rappelle à nos secouer pas
les bébés par contre vous pouvez les
jeter par terre et rebondissent le jeu
est un jeu 100% Pacifique puisque vous
ne pouvez pas tuer les ennemis c'est
donc vraiment littéralement un jeu de
plateforme pur avec des trucs à ramasser
de temps en temps comme par exemple des
tablettes des dix commandements qui
traînent sur
ça doit être de l'Ancien Testament
celui-là je le connais pas bon alors le
jour on va pas en parler 1000 ans c'est
quasi toujours la même chose le gameplay
il change quasiment pas ça se finit en
une dizaine de minutes à peine par un
message sobre
bravo tu as gagné et maintenant tu
attends tu viens de jeter à la flotte là
je suis vends large de Noé même principe
vous jouez donc Noé qui doit aller
chercher un couple de chaque espèce et
les ramener à son bateau bon là il y en
a trois mais après tout même les animaux
ont droit de s'amuser hein il est
balaise d'ailleurs un Noe il soulève des
taureaux à Manu comme ça en fait
d'ailleurs petit aparté Noé c'est le
personnage de la Bible qui a eu le droit
au plus de jeu il a eu des FPS façon
Wolfenstein des jeux de plateforme très
sympa où tu butes des animaux bizarres
d'ailleurs Dieu il a dit deux animaux
par espèce
[Musique]
et même récemment des muceaux où il met
des grosses tatanes à des paquets
d'infidèles à coups de pied enflammé
pas sûr que ce soit dans la Bible
bref revenons au jeu on ramasse donc
différents objets qui servent à attirer
les animaux par exemple vous pouvez
attirer les cochons avec les bananes
comme dans la vraie vie et une fois tous
les animaux ramenés on met tout ça dans
la cage allez hop allez voilà le tigre
le léopard et la panthère avec le koala
et
voilà châssis mon boulot le jeu est
d'ailleurs toujours truffé de petites
citations de la Bible event tout i want
to the valley of the shadow of death ah
[ __ ] ils ont même cité Coolio et enfin
le dernier jeu de cette cartouche David
et Goliath le fameux mythe du petit est
faible qui réussit à triompher contre le
fort grâce à un caillou lancé par une
fronde et pas du tout ici c'est un jeu
David et Goliath sauf que il y a pas de
Goliath et que David il a pas de fronde
et que à la place de se battre et bien
aura base des moutons voilà et du coup
c'est plutôt high des Goliath
bon et bref vu que le jeu est
strictement identique aux deux autres je
vais même pas perdre mon temps dessus
ouais mais après évidemment faut
relativiser le but de faire un jeu sur
la Bible c'est pas spécialement de faire
un jeu c'est d'abord de faire du
prosélytisme donc le gameplay passe
souvent au second plan l'objectif c'est
d'abord de vérifier la connaissance en
catéchisme des gamins pas très
intéressant donc du coup pour faire
avaler la religion aux enfants plus
facilement on a dû trouver une solution
c'est de faire des vrais jeux
ouais c'est c'est un vrai jeu Captain
Bible and the dome of darkness vous êtes
donc Captain Bible le super héros
catholique membre de la Bible corpe et
le jeu se passe dans un univers fictif
où le monde entier est catholique tous
non un clan d'irréductible zaté
s'acharne à croire à des
mensonges la ville a été recouverte par
un doc d'anti vérité qui fait que les
gens ne croient plus en Dieu la solution
envahir la cité par la force
[Musique]
ah oui capitaine c'était le bon vieux
temps mais maintenant on fait leur
parler avant bref à la place on va donc
vous envoyer vous par un tout petit trou
que notre rayon magique a réussi à
perforer dans le dôme pour y affronter
les marchand et il répandre la foi
et pour accomplir cette mission dans ce
jeu vous utiliserez un astucieux système
de combat à base de verser par exemple
les ennemis vous disent un truc de
malade mental du genre l'arc-en-ciel est
juste une réflexion de la lumière à
travers l'eau mais quoi mais ils ont
pris de la drogue ou quoi ou bien des
fois des choses plus complexes comme les
enfants sont purés innocents il faut les
laisser vivre leur vie tranquille sans
trop les faire chier et là vous répondez
NON NON et vous leur balancez un verset
à la gueule la folie est attachée au
cœur de l'enfant et seul la correction
et là pas filmer et son cadavre c'est
des composent amen fils de [ __ ] bon
alors après je fais des raccourcis c'est
pas vraiment le verset qui permet de
battre les ennemis c'est l'épée que vous
leur plantez dans le crâne après avoir
cité de verser mais pour avoir le droit
à la scène de bateau il faut d'abord
trouver le bon verset de la Bible à
opposer à leur phrase c'est un peu de
genre de la self motivation vous savez
cela dit pour pouvoir vaincre les robots
impies il faudra aller récupérer les
verser sur différentes cyberbes
dispersés dans le monde parce que bah
visiblement sans ça votre personnage ne
les connaît pas ce qui est bizarre hein
pour un mec qui s'appelle Captain Bible
attendez une seconde comment ça vous
l'avez jamais lu et en vrai pour pas
mentir le gameplay est étrangement assez
efficace on se surprend un peu des fois
de lire tous les versets de la Bible
pour savoir quoi répondre à quel ennemi
en fonction de leur phrase c'est un peu
comme un genre de rabattle
sans rap et où à la fin tu fais fondre
le visage du pardon après je vais pas
vous mentir plus on avance dans le jeu
plus il y a de phrases à retenir et ça
devient un peu le bordel et honnêtement
c'est un peu relou ça serait bien qui en
fait qui est un genre de
livre qui compile toutes les citations
de Jésus vous voyez bref c'est donc que
je plutôt original et en fait presque ça
pas si on oublie que vous êtes un Mania
commissaire parce que les robots ils
essayent pas vraiment de vous tuer
pendant le jeu en fait ils sont juste là
quand soudain
vous fera perdre de la foi et arriver à
zéro vous deviendrez un AT et c'est le
game over la terre est une boule de feu
géante qui a refroidi
vous pourrez aussi bien sûr comme dans
tous les RPG améliorer vos capacités par
exemple en allant prier à la chapelle
Dieu vous demandera alors un verset de
la Bible précise du genre dans quel
verset ça parle de l'épée sacrée et si
vous répondez juste il vous récompensera
et c'est une bonne réponse vous avez
gagné ce magnifique M16 à 4 à variante
semi-automatique ou coup par coup avec
son chargeur de munition 5,50 par contre
si vous répondez mal il ghostnera votre
appel avec un bon gros vu sans plus de
réponse et le but du jeu bah c'est quoi
finalement et bien il va falloir libérer
cette prisonniers retenus dans la ville
qui sont devenus des impies dont
certains qui prient un mec qui ressemble
à Steve Jobs avec un mouton sur la tête
ouais les cadeaux derrière ce jeu
avaient une vision assez particulière de
la technologie bonjour je suis cadre
supérieur en créatif management chez
Apple avec d'ailleurs un vrai dialogue
qui marquera l'histoire du jeu vidéo je
pense c'est Jésus réincarner non c'est
pas lui si c'est lui non c'est pas lui
si c'est lui non c'est pas lui
je n'ai aucun argument
et pour les sauver ça sera le même
système de combat que les versets il
faudra s'appuyer sur des sur des facts
comme les pages de la Bible et une fois
tous les présidents délibérés et bien
vous montrerez tous ensemble dans un
immense robot géant pour finir de
libérer la ville impie en mettant des
énormes patates de forains dans les
immeubles tout en balançant des
punchlines de la Bible en majuscule le
fameux mégalore mais l'ironie est
présente quand même
prenez ça maudire au bout de Satan vous
ne pouvez rien contre mon robot
une seconde
oui bon alors tout ça c'est très sympa
on parle des jeux sur la Bible mais très
bien qu'il manque le principal intéressé
quand même en vrai Jésus à ma
connaissance n'apparaît quasiment jamais
dans les jeux vidéo c'est
essentiellement ou Noé ou Moïse à la
limite sauf dans le jeu qu'on vient de
trouver
qui est pas le meilleur
mon plaisir the you testament de ces
jeux au pif et sur la Bible vous
incarnez un membre de
K-Pop indienne perdu en Israël aux
alentours de leurs héros il y a aussi
des soldats roumains en version Netflix
alors j'avoue que j'ai hésité à parler
de ce jeu parce que au début on pensait
que c'était un genre de jeu un peu troll
mais en fait non pas vraiment on a
cherché des infos et ça a l'air d'être
un jeu fait tout à fait heureusement
sauf que rien n'a de sens pourquoi ces
gens sont dans l'eau pourquoi il y a un
mec qui se noie pendant cette
cinématique et et lui c'est qui c'est
Lui Jésus
et pourquoi Jésus il a une grosse barre
de fer dans ses mains là qu'est-ce qu'il
fait lui là il joue à cache-cache ou
alors c'est genre ils l'ont mis comme ça
avec les mains comme ça pour nous faire
comprendre qu'il est aveugle
depuis la naissance j'aurais toujours
pas accepté ah pourquoi les gens se
foutent des taloches comme ça sur la
tronche de manière complètement random
autour de moi bon et on est d'accord je
ne vais même pas parler des graphismes
là c'est même plus tiré sur ambulance là
c'est [ __ ] l'ambulance directement
alors de ce que j'ai compris nous jouons
dans un genre de Bible alternative
où il est temps de retrouver Jésus mais
j'ai beau elle est de cartes en car pour
retrouver Jésus le seul truc qui se
passe c'est que les gens se foutent sur
la gueule tout le temps c'est où que
j'aille ça finit un baston c'est dingue
c'est ma deuxième run là j'ai tabassé
quelqu'un je suis allé en prison on a
crucifié et soudain
[Musique]
un seigneur pardonne-les ils sont codés
avec le cul oui d'ailleurs si le look
des personnages change à chaque fois
c'est parce que les skins sont générés
aléatoirement ce qui donne parfois des
scènes assez improbables Michael est fan
de tuning il va se faire téléporter en
Jordanie en l'an 0 et va se rendre
compte que un prophète c'est pas si
facile après vous vous pourrez créer
votre personnage grâce à un excellent
éditeur de perso regardez il y a
vraiment tout il y a la taille
l'expression du visage avec plein de
choix différents
le sexe gros ou femme vous pourrez
vraiment faire un personnage qui vous
correspond
[Musique]
peuple d'Israël je suis Broly le Super
Sayen légendaire
[Musique]
ah mais vraiment il faudrait contacter
des chaînes d'histoire alternative et si
Judas était Broly vraiment je sais pas
trop quoi dire d'autre en fait regardez
ce bordel on dirait une zone de départ
dans un Mo ou personne ne sait où aller
et ces dialogues qui n'ont aucun sens
genre il y a un moment où il y a un PNJ
qui me dit ah ben qu'est-ce que vous
faites debout à cette heure-ci et là tu
te dis ah bah peut-être parce que c'est
tard dans le jeu et qu'en fait il faut
que j'aille me coucher et que je trouve
une auberge mais non il faut juste
s'asseoir en fait et là ça va
bizarre à partir de 22h30 tout le monde
s'assoit c'est la règle de Rome après on
a quand même des moments mémorables
comme quand Jésus si tobywan Kenobi mais
rendons à César ce qui lui appartient il
y a quand même un fond de jeu vous avez
trois barres en bas votre énergie votre
santé mentale et la troisième c'est ta
barre de je sais pas de chakra peut-être
c'est un truc comme ça vu que tu peux la
recharger en méditant j'ai juste pu
que quand ta barre de santé mentale
arrive à zéro tu perds le contrôle de
ton personnage
[Musique]
alors je vous jure vraiment qu'on savait
pas que ça allait se passer comme ça
quand on a créé ce personnage et
d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé Jésus sauf que ma
santé mentale est à zéro alors qu'est-ce
qui va se passer oh non broline de pas
Jésus on va perdre de sponsor
phrase aucun sens ah non ça va on a
droit à un discours sur l'amitié on ne
peut pas taper Jésus ouf Broly qu'est-ce
qui te fait si mal que tu as besoin de
me blesser pour en guérir ne peux-tu
voir que cette attaque est un appel à
l'aide une personne qui contrôle sa vie
n'a pas besoin de se déchaîner avec
chaque coup tu te condamnes toi-même à
la vie d'un animal et te déni ton
potentiel divin si tu comprenais que
tout est connecté alors tu ne te blesse
pas toi-même en blessant les autres
[Musique]
au final les jeux sur la religion bon
bah écoutez tout le monde est libre
d'acheter ce qu'il veut oui
effectivement c'est du prosélytisme mais
bon au moins la couleur est annoncée tu
sais ce que tu achètes et quelque part
c'est presque plus honnête que si ça
avait été dissimulé dans un emballage
plus neutre
oui je ne me mouille pas et il reste
tout un tas de jeux qu'on a pas du tout
abordé largement assez pour un épisode
de en tout cas et qui continue même à
sortir de nos jours puisque dans
quelques mois doit sortir un jeu qui
s'appelle littéralement je m'appelle
Jésus-Christ et qui ressemble à un genre
de Skyrim regardez ça on tire des lasers
comme Iron Man on a des super pouvoirs
de charpentier on recharge sa cosmo
énergie on doit purifier des zones de
cristaux démoniaque on rentre dans des
enfants pour tuer les virus de
l'intérieur et notre père c'est Lionel
Messi j'ai déjà fait le prologue de mon
côté je vous garantis que ça sera le
GOTY 2012 sans aucun souci j'espère que
le jeu marchera et qui fera une suite
mais c'est vrai que c'est audacieux de
sortir ça sur PC hein j'ai trop hâte de
la version modée avec Shrek à la place
de Jésus ok c'est bon j'ai fait tous les
jeux sur la Bible maintenant je peux
retourner en enfer pour parler au type
pour les montrer les résultats ok Seb il
faut que tu me tues OK
un pistolet en plus tu risques de me
rater à cette distance il faut une mort
rapide et efficace
[Musique]
ah bah voilà vous êtes revenu alors prêt
pour l'examen attendez quel examen je
crois que je devais aller au paradis
maintenant ouais d'abord il y a un
examen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je connais la réponse
comme les rois mages
[Musique]
je te suivrai où tu iras j'irai fidèle
comme une ombre jusqu'à destination
bien merci à tous je viens d'avoir vos
résultats j'ai l'immense privilège de
vous annoncer que vous êtes tous amis
[Musique]
en plus vous avez fait trois fautes
d'orthographe à votre prénom [ __ ] de
faire en fait même monsieur kiki a eu
plus de points que vous
avant
compris du coup si je transmets vos
résultats vous allez faire chuter la
moyenne de tous les établissements
ce que je vous propose c'est que je
déchire ça et qu'on fasse comme c'est
rien ne s'était passé
bon voyage de retour monsieur grenier
[Musique]
ça va tu t'évanouis pendant 5 secondes
tu as perdu une dentes
tu peux la garder ou tu veux la
récupérer
[Musique]
ah oui au fait d'ailleurs regarde
monsieur Lopez est mort oh non pas
monsieur Lopez il faisait le meilleur
meringues de la ville et mais j'ai
réussi à choper un des derniers factile
c'est délicieuse meringue
[Musique]
c'est Noël
et cette faute
et comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]